el un presidente que ya sabe cómo ganar
sin ser favorito su rival un candidato
que aventaja en las encuestas pero
siempre ha sido de la eterna aspirante
el presidente de la cndh tranvía el
candidato presidencial demócrata joe
biden ya están en nashville para su
último debate antes de las elecciones la
universidad de belmondo acoge el segundo
y último debate presidencial de la
campaña en esta ocasión con unos
micrófonos que podrán cerrarse por parte
de la moderadora para evitar episodios
caóticos como el del primer cara a cara
serán seis temas el hobbit 19 la familia
estadounidense la carrera política el
cambio climático la seguridad nacional y
el liderazgo by the night' trump tendrán
dos minutos para ello solos en cada una
de sus primeras respuestas sobre estos
temas antes de su partida a nashville
padre había dejado claro su mensaje
esperemos que él juegue según las reglas
esperemos que les hayan hecho la prueba
a todos esperemos que ya esté todo
arreglado
trump por su parte ya libre del joven 19
que impidió que participara en otro
debate dejó claro que sus reglas no son
las de todos el mandatario compartió una
entrevista con el programa sixty minutes
de cbs antes de la fecha prevista de
estreno argumentando que el programa no
era objetivo y buscaba atacarlo usted va
a obtener equidad pero está de acuerdo
con unas preguntas difíciles no no está
de acuerdo con unas preguntas difíciles
voy a ser franco usted no le hace
preguntas difíciles a bailén el último
debate a sólo 12 días de las elecciones
y aunque ya más de 40 millones de
estadounidenses han votado de manera
anticipada que se cara a cara se muestra
como una oportunidad clave ante los
estados pendulares aquellos en donde no
siempre gana el mismo partido